oh me oh my you already know us will mow
wet give me instrumental and say go back
I'm gonna hit it straight I bought the
dope black-owned recaps the out top cuz
I'm a coke back at the Georgia Dome
William Moore is a Pro Bowl safety for
the Atlanta Falcons but off the dome he
is known as the best freestyle lyricist
in the NFL same with the game on the
Sunday about The Dropper instrumental
through the wire Kanye top down Bentley
coupe swinging on the Sunday I've been
doing rapping since I can't even
remember first it was something I picked
up just having fun with and you know a
few people has in football you know gave
him a little motivation are you pretty
good as I started with simple rounds
back in sixth grade and now you know as
my vocabulary got stronger you know I'm
graduated my mom wised up a little bit I
can put them right into my flow mores
lyrical talents became nationally known
in 2012 when the Falcons uploaded the
defense's freestyle Friday tradition to
YouTube and Willie Moe was clearly the
lead MC specialize in this bout Dania
shots out to my deep block this will
Mobile it a coup we parted this
freestyling is sort of like football you
know when you're on the field you know
how time to think you got to react and
that's the same thing in freestyling you
know once the be fluent and just going
with the B just react and now we bout to
go into the Mercedes being super doing
what we've drawn here alone cellphones
you don't wanna play with wheels I'm
aiming for you don't get home boy I read
before Lana I'm the Missouri hammer and
I'm all new you camera the homework the
Pro Bowlers talents what the Mike have
spread so far that even platinum selling
rap star French Montana had to check it
out
I'm gonna bring the beat back yeah ride
around town spin that heat young Willie
when I'm in New York just like my
nickname was Diddy yeah yeah yeah the
day I like the rider Papa would and
there the other day I like the ride and
get still oh no I'm bout to drop a punch
on but any given second I can drop
because it's crushed I'm running up on
the wrong guy each of once like it's
lunchtime you know one huge the
guarantees you won't mind
I'm the one that run upon you with the
camera I love it you know why cuz you
could tell he was trying to be a rapper
before he's gotta be on football player
you can tell he got that vibe with him
like he's just you know he got his swag
I love his swag with it I just felt like
his delivery was strong sometimes you
can have that slap we just need somebody
to show you how to put it together
whenever you ready I'm ready seinem owe
me a puff sign together you know make it
happen they just have a cipher can we do
that I'll be the first to say it on
camera let's have a cypher if they have
time on a season two days off that's all
get in one place to have a cycler
you